voilà il la voie vers la qualité
football fr
[Musique]
le but local est très excellent c'est
très bon
aussi les trois amis en main c'est très
bon c'est naturel
[Musique]
non
peuple la plus avant de commencer oui
mais oui moi et plus de sept moines
carte du look arago
[Musique]
ça prend du temps quand même c'est un
ensemble d'activités de rencontre
aussi bien au niveau des services de
l'état qui au niveau des
transformateurs de tout l'hémicycle est
là et même les éleveurs nous sommes
actuellement dans le crochet chiche pour
qu'enfin après officiellement on
reconnaît que notre poulet local
s'appelle effectivement les six
collectes
[Musique]
là